no this trailer new venom trailer out
and I have said a lot of not
particularly nice or positive or
enthusiastic things about this movie
over the last year year and a half or so
broad strokes I'll just reiterate this
off the bat
making a venom solo movie without first
establishing him in Spider Man is not a
particularly good idea making a venom
origin solo movie with no clear ties to
spider-man whatsoever is definitely a
very bad idea
that having been said when the
announcement came in that this was gonna
be hard arm was gonna be horror tinged I
actually since that announcement I've
had a tiny bit of hope not a ton it's
they said I actually I want to revise
that it's not even hope but I can see
the one possible way this might actually
work I actually don't have any faith
that Sony will get it there but what
I've said is if you're going to not tie
this despite a man and if you are going
to go r-rated then horror is a decent
way to go because you can do possession
tropes you can do body horror and like
do it properly like really dig into what
it is that's happening to him and his
body and the fact that he's sharing a
mind almost with this thing you could
really get a nerving and again no fake
that that's what Sony will pull off but
that is the sliver of maybe there's a
way for this to work that I've been
clinging to for a while now because look
I like venom I like venom as a care
I'm not gonna go so far as to say he's a
good character because you know I fell
in love with the character while I was
10 and as a 10 year old I had no taste
but I've still got affection for the guy
so I I would like this to succeed but
the whole premise is initially fall but
let's talk about this trailer
specifically so having said that this is
a bad idea there's a surprising amount
in this trailer that I either like or am
i that works well enough so like a big
thing that I like I love the voice of
the symbiotes of venom I love that voice
a lot now I'm I'll admit I'm kind of a
sucker for just really deep voices I
like them just as a thing but you know I
I don't know who's doing the voice or I
mean for all I know it's Tom Hardy just
with a heck of a lot of reverb and pitch
down added to it but whoever it is
instead of just going generic growly
deep voice which is is what you get
sometimes they do appear there so
there's some personality behind that
which is get I love I mean I I could
listen all day to people like James Earl
Jones Tony Todd Keith David especially
so I that was a big thing for me and
having heard that voice having heard the
symbiosis voice the sort of Mike Tyson s
kind of soft-spoken and almost Lisp that
Tom Hardy has going suddenly makes more
sense because it becomes a point of
contrast cuz he is very soft-spoken and
we do not have confirmation that he is
we are keeping his reporter backstory I
mean it looks like that is gonna be
factoring this that's what a that's was
gonna put him on the radar of what looks
like our nominal villain I'll get to him
in a second and I think that's a decent
angle because you know we if we're not
gonna have spider
we really need to give him some kind of
grounding him something and if we make
him a reporter especially a reporter
with the conscience which he seems to be
seems to be if not successfully at least
trying to be kind of a crusading
reporter thing and if he's going for
that than that okay that's a good start
that's a good basis now I mentioned the
villain and when I say the villa I mean
this generic Big Pharma business guy you
know eh he seems fine I'm sure he'll be
fine he'll be functional he'll be as
functional as say Darren cross from
ant-man or heck and got as functional as
Francis from Deadpool but again stopping
and thinking about it okay removing
spider-man from Venom's origin is a
stupid idea but if you're gonna do it
having a villain who is involved in the
creation of venom and who can serve as a
focal point for the hatred from both
Eddie and the symbiote to zero in on him
because if you remove Peter Parker I
think it's it's really central to venom
that he is driven to a certain degree by
hate or at least that's that's a big
part of how the symbiote manipulates him
to do what it wants to do is through his
hatred so if you give him a proper
target for his hate like I expect this
guy will be that not fully but to a
degree does fill the void left by the
absence of Peter Parker so okay I don't
expect this guy to be a particularly
great villain but that's functional
narrative Lee that works there's some
cool little moments like him you know
just spotting the woman who was you know
obviously trying to follow him he's like
you you suck at this
and so that's cool and then you know we
get you know we get into in the action
looks okay it varies from shot to shot
some of it looks a little better than
others but honestly for the most part it
looks pretty good not awesome but pretty
good so I'm looking at the various
components of this thing and
thinking to myself okay there's a couple
of things I genuinely like I now have
context for some of the stuff that made
me concerned before so I'm not as
concerned a lot of the other stuff I'm
seeing is you know it's gonna be fine
it's not gonna be a detriment the few
things that aren't very good like the
tagline embrace your inner antihero
that's not a phrase that's stupid it's
embrace your inner demon why isn't it
your inner demon right but but that's a
marketing fault that's not necessarily
the fault of the film so fine pass on
that the whole him like flying off the
motorcycle and the tendrils go out and
pull him back on the motorcycle that's
dumb and it doesn't look very good it
may not be a completely finished effect
but it's also not a great notion but
that's a quick moment I expect it'll be
a fairly quick moment in the film as
well so okay I won't hold that against
it so so far I've got stuff that I like
stuff that works well enough and even
the stuff that doesn't work I doesn't
make me doesn't strike me as an
indicator that it would sink the whole
movie the few things that I'm going to
okay that doesn't work so getting
towards the end of the trailer all this
thing has to do to get me on board and
actually maybe start getting excited is
nail the creature itself oh that's a
shame I'm exaggerating a little bit for
cover comedic effect there it's it's
alright it's not quite there it's close
though it's in the ballpark I mean first
of all the fair's fair this is miles
better than what he looked like in
spider-man 3 not even a comparison I
liked how much emphasis there is on the
teeth that you know as the things coming
over and closing his head like your eyes
while your eyes zoom in on whatever is
isn't black because the black is
enveloping in so it's just the teeth all
coming together like that that's that is
a good way to do venneman to get the
proper emphasis that was always my big
thing with spider-man 3 he's like he
just kind of gave him jaggedy vampire
comes you like no
it needs to be like either huge or more
teeth and is reasonable or makes any
sense or both and this went for both so
that's cool the the tongue I mean it's
true to the comic he always kind of had
like a tentacle tendril tubular kind of
tubular man kind of tongue so it's true
to that but I don't know it's not it's
not quite working for me I mean maybe
it's it's again maybe it's the effect is
missing like a little last minute last
polish on it because it's it doesn't
look attached with in his with in his
mouth so that's not quite there for me
but even though it's like two words that
come out of that thing's mouth after it
fully forms I do like hearing that voice
come out of it so it didn't nail the
look for me it's not like yes but I'm
also kind of going okay I think maybe
part of the thing my friend Paul pointed
this out it might have worked better if
there was less definition like basically
in anything that isn't the eyes and the
teeth if it was more of a black void
everywhere else as opposed to being kind
of shiny glistening me and you know
almost you need to have a texture that
might have been a better way to go but
oddly enough at the end of this trailer
I find myself going I can't write this
movie off again I want to emphasize I
don't have hope that this is going to be
good but that path that incredibly
narrow like pinpoint size path that I
said I could I could see being the path
to being a good movie I can still see it
like I had the the things that I see
here nothing obliterates the possibility
of being able to walk that line
so maybe which is weird again
acknowledging that it's possible for it
to be decent is not the same as saying
it will be good but I would have
expected by now to have seen something
that would have made me go yeah there's
my confirmation I know for certain that
this is gonna be awful and I don't have
it yet
like III had it like by this time you
know sort of second trailer area I have
my confirmation force a ghost in the
shell' that I knew I was gonna hate it
um you know something like Justice
League second trailer I'm like this is
not good and even though Justice League
was better than I thought it was that I
thought it was gonna be still wasn't
great so but I I'm looking at this this
trailer and it's better that I'm right
now in a better place than either myself
then neither of those two examples you
know where I was prepared to write it
off I I thought this trailer was gonna
be like cool this is where I get to
write off this movie and I can't which
surprises me I will be very curious to
see how this plays out what are your
thoughts on the new venom trailer does
it give you hope does it look like
something that could work for you do you
think it looks like complete and utter
crap and I am just being weirdly
optimistic and giving this thing a
benefit of the doubt you know enough
rope to hang itself with because I have
an affection for the character whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do is that just support
me on patreon follow me on Twitter or
listen to my podcasts etc etc etc so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]